today's video has been made possible by
EXA the innovators who revolutionize the
way we carry our
Essentials EXA renowned for creating the
world's first trackable wallet is on a
mission to upgrade your everyday carry
they've taken the next step in
Innovation crafting sustainable wallets
bags and accessories designed to enhance
your daily life meet their super slim
wallet half the size of conventional
wallets yet it holds over 12 cards and
your cash effortlessly experience quick
card access like never before thanks to
their signature trigger mechanism
worried about Data Theft fear not their
built-in RFID blocking protects you from
Wireless skimming and data theft but
that's not all exter's solar powered
tracker lets you keep tabs on your
wallet's location right from your phone
use the two-way ringing feature or
receive separation alerts just 2 hours
in the sun equals 3 months of charge
don't wait any longer upgrade your
everyday carry with EXA and join the
future of smart and sustainable
Essentials don't wait any longer upgrade
your everyday carry with EXA and join
the future of smart and sustainable
Essentials for being part of this
community by using the code politic at
checkout and using the link in the
description you can get up to 45%
discount for exter's New Year
[Music]
sale think about it if we asked any of
you why North Korea is so poor I'm
pretty sure that in most cases the short
answer would be very clear it's obvious
Josh because it's a communist country
however that very answer has a catch why
is North Korea so much poorer than for
example China or even Cuba why is it a
much poorer and more backward country
than the Soviet Union or Tito's
Yugoslavia was and not only that visual
politic Community it may surprise you
but North Korea was not always such a
miserable country nor did it always have
the levels of extreme poverty that it
now suffers what's more there was a time
when North Korea was viewed as a kind of
model of socialism in the Socialist
world and South Korea on the on the
other hand as a poor and corrupt blot on
the capitalist World North Korea even
hold on to your chair went so far as to
donate food to South Korea something
that these days seems totally crazy
North Korea delivers flood aid supplies
to South 370 open trucks dropped off
tons of rice medicine and cloth that the
North had volunteered as relief Aid to
victims of recent floods in the south at
that time in the early 1980s North
Korean grain production exceeded 10
million tons per day today it is less
than half of that in fact North Korea
has suffered such a debuck that nowadays
not even the staunchest supporters of
Communism would dare to boast about the
economic or Social Development of this
country unless of course they are fans
of the Absurd now why do we say that
North Korea was a model country for the
supporters of socialist revolutions what
has happened since then to make this
country the opposite today what are the
main reasons for the severe and
widespread levels of extreme poverty
there well visual politic viewers we're
going to answer all these questions in
detail in this video so let's get
[Applause]
[Music]
going let's see when we say that
communism is not the only thing that
explains the extreme poverty in North
Korea today we have to look at the past
specifically to that dark period of the
20th century when the world was divided
into two large blocks the capitalist
side and and the Communist block and pay
attention because in this video we are
not going to tell you that North Korea
was richer than South Korea until almost
the mid-70s because you will have heard
that many times before even on this
channel however what you may not have
heard as much about is that until about
1993 and that's not so long ago North
Korea surpassed China in GDP per capita
which could be interpreted greatly
simplified to mean that it was a richer
country let me repeat
1993 that really wasn't that long ago
especially if we take into account the
abyss that separates the same two
countries today because we can basically
say that this hermit country went from
being the best student with the best
grades in the Communist orbit to not
being able to pass even a single
[Music]
test well one of the aspects that is not
often talked about is that within the
Communist block there were also
significant differences between
countries in terms of wealth and
development and yes North Korea was
among the wealthy and advanced students
of the time within the reality of the
Communist block we are talking about the
1960s and above all the 1970s what more
in the 1980s North Koreans were somewhat
richer than they are today yet this
country is no more communist now than it
was in the 1980s so there has to be an
explanation what on Earth has happened
what could explain the extreme poverty
that has plagued North Korea for decades
well in order to understand the fall of
this country I think it is essential to
to First understand the rise the ascent
because yes the truth is that North
Korea had relatively happy times and to
a large extent what was done and how it
was done then determined the result we
know today visual politic viewers get
ready to be surprised stay
tuned the model socialist
[Music]
[Applause]
country the Korean War which pitted the
two newly formed sister countries North
and South Korea against each other
between 1950 and 1953 destroyed almost
everything and plunged the two states
into a massive economic and humanitarian
crisis at that time the exit of one
country or the other from the war
economically speaking was seen in a
certain light as a way of demonstrating
which of the two systems the capitalist
or the Communist was better today this
may seem outrageous but at the time
there were some doubts even among many
intellectuals and academics in the
western world and in the United States
itself for this reason the two great
powers of the time took giving Aid to
their respective Korean Ally during the
post-war period very seriously the
United States and other Western allies
helped South Korea with an outpouring of
money and low or no interest loans
meanwhile the Soviet Union and China
also flooded North Korea with money
specifically between 1950 and 1970 they
deployed some $2 billion at the time and
on top of this must be added an enormous
amount of of resources that were key to
the Reconstruction of the country and
also to North Korean
[Music]
industrialization in order to achieve
its set objectives to industrialize at
full speed and win the race against its
Southern neighbor the North Korean state
made use of several formulas on the one
hand the traditional economic planning
that is characteristic of communist
dictatorships on the other hand the
creation of a social movement to support
all its objectives well the plan was
initially relatively successful the
5-year plan of 1957 to 1960 managed to
solve the major post-war food and
housing problems and left the country
ready to LEAP into production Mass
industrialization and development or so
it was
thought between 1953 when the war ended
and 1958 the average industrial growth
rate in North Korea was 43% per year
despite this the street level economy
was not developing at the same Pace to
fix that in 1958 the Kima movement was
created a version of Soviet stavis which
was interpreted as North Korea's
competition to mau's Great Leap Forward
however unlike what happened with the
Chinese Great Leap Forward there is some
consensus that the kma movement had some
success the aim of the plan was above
all to increase the productivity of
workers in order to achieve this hardly
any material compensations were
introduced but production targets were
set even doubling production year on
year and the best workers were presented
by the propaganda Outlets as having
superhuman qualities and as being true
heroes of the
people and the truth is that the plan
partially worked industrial and
agricultural production did not double
in one year but Kima had an
effect for example industrial production
with special attention to steel
production grew 53% in 1959 over the
previous year workers began to lengthen
their work in hours to 10 and 12 hours a
day and began to work on weekends and
holidays all to achieve the objectives
set in the framework of an enormous
patriotic fervor be that as it may the
point is that in the 1960s and 1970s the
country was doing reasonably well
considering where it had started from in
the 1970s it recorded year-on-year gddp
growth rates of more than 10% with years
in which it even approached 25% at that
time agricultural production was
developing to triple its output in
little more than a decade and cheap oil
was arriving from Soviet Union along
with industrial technology from the
German Democratic Republic and other
Eastern European countries all this
facilitated the development of a much
more advanced industry that was
available in South Korea or China at the
time in fact between the early 1970s and
1985 nominal GDP per capita Rose from
$384 to
$836 yes it was still a very low level
but to give you an idea China only
managed to break the $600 per capita
Mark for the first time 10 years later
in 1995 also Pyongyang was experiencing
rapid Urban growth new industries were
setting up around the capital and the
city had become a socialist
[Music]
model very wide and clean Avenues
manicured Gardens fountains street cars
Subways everything seemed to be going
reasonably well there were few if any
cases like this in the Communist world
at the time and for many what was
happening in North Korea was almost a
miracle the rapid growth of that period
was accompanied by an increase in life
expectancy to 70 years and a reduction
in the infant mortality rate from about
120 children per 1,000 to about
30 even in the 1980s pongyang became one
of the fashion capitals of Asia with
great influence in China and other
countries of the Socialist orbit at that
time but not only that the other
Cornerstone of North Korean growth in
the 1960s and 1970s in addition to the
steel industry was also mining minerals
such as magnesite which is used for
example in the steel industry or in
construction zinc tungsten and iron all
of them were used not only in North
Korea's own industry but were also
exported in large quantities in exchange
for foreign currency oil and Technology
as a result if there was one communist
country ready to take off at that time
all eyes were on this country
[Music]
of course all this allowed the country
to have a certain International
relevance in the Socialist World an
influence that pongyang exploited and
what's more hoped to expand beyond the
other side of the curtain how well you
see North Korea wanted to develop its
own version of globalization in the 70s
and 80s a model that sought to turn the
country into a sort of bridge between
the countries of the Communist block and
the non-aligned countries and so North
Korea began to strengthen ties and
promote business with African countries
such as Algeria and also with others in
the Middle East and Southeast Asia they
even established relations with some
Latin American countries and supported
revolutionary or anti-colonial movements
in Africa all this may seem
contradictory to those of you who know
something about North Korea after all
the je ideology which is the indigenous
North Korean version of socialism is
based on utari and you are right but the
reality is a bit more complex
[Applause]
[Music]
as we've seen North Korea was not a
country that was massively successful
but well it was more or less a good
place to live in the Communist context
of course and it certainly was worlds
apart from its current situation there
was a certain Halo of prosperity so then
how and why did it come to this sorry
State of Affairs how did a reasonably
prosperous country by socialist
standards end up suffering one of the
worst famines of mankind in the late
1990s what key mistakes were made to
turn it into such an impoverished and
backward country well here we tell you
all about it I'll tell you right now
that if North Korea's history were REM
movie this would be the precise moment
when the world would get tense and we
would all start to suspect that
something bad was about to happen and
guess what that's exactly what happened
listen
up the reasons for
failure North Korean political ideology
is marked by a Doctrine its own version
of Communism imposed by the dictator Kim
ilung ju ju in practice implies the
adoption of autarchy as a way of
Defending sovereignty and Revolution
we're talking about a system that is a
kind of mixture between I do it myself
and I don't need anyone's help seasoned
with tons of communist theory that is ju
a philosophy that may sound great in
theory but in practice is much more
difficult than assembling a piece of
Ikea furniture without instructions but
stop wait a minute because in spite of
all this as we told you earlier North
Korea traded a lot with other countries
of the Socialist
block not only were Goods imported and
exported to these countries but also a
great deal of money was borrowed from
other communist countries as well as
from Western and even Japanese Banks
pongyang had operations with more than
100 Banks in 17 countries particularly
during the 1970s this money was intended
to finance the expansion of mining in
the country construction and food
imports mining in addition was basically
being doped with more production to
counteract the falling prices that was
occurring with some of the minerals
exported by the country the sector had
become a kind of Golden Goose for the
Pyongyang regime and the only way to
continue obtaining resources from abroad
in a context of falling prices was to
expand production more and
more obviously this was a lousy
idea
soon the North Koreans began to be
unable to repay the loans their debts
were rescheduled in 1977 1980 and 1984
and North Korea ended up not being able
to pay its loans that is going into
default this was the first reason for
the beginning of the end of North Korean
optimism North Korea is told of loan
default the total amount of principal
and interest owed is about $770 million
out of about $1.65 billion to $2.7 5
billion that North Korea is believed to
owe to the non-communist world the rest
is mostly held by Japanese Banks the
capital and interest acrw with financial
institutions now amounts to
approximately $3.6 billion us and that
is taking into account a large write-off
with Russia amounting to 90% of the
debts with this former Communist party
amounting to 90% of the debts with this
former communist partner in total the
country's foreign debt is between $6
billion and $15 billion Accord according
to the international Journal of Korean
unification studies but let's not get
[Music]
sidetracked the fact is that the
non-payment was so severe that it left
such Dante esque situations as this
North Korea's never paid for Volvos
still going strong after nearly 50 years
the Swedish national export credits
guarantee board e estimated the
outstanding debt on the 1,000 Volvo
vehicles North Korea ordered nearly 50
years ago at 2.9 billion Swedish Kona
$267 million the initial purchase
agreement was 600 million Crona and I
know what you are thinking but Josh no
country starves to death and is
indefinitely Frozen in time for 30 years
simply because it has debts there must
be something else yes you are right to
say that North Korea is stuck in time
just because of unpaid debts would be
like saying that a party is ruined just
because the ice runs out it stands to
reason that there must be more factors
and yes the truth is that there are a
lot more apart from being incapable of
adapting their productive model to
Global changes other fatal mistakes were
made along the way mistakes that have a
lot to do with the lack of Market
perspective the lack of supervision and
oversight of those in power and of
course corruption two key elements go a
long way toward explaining why North
Korea is in such a dire state
today the first is that in the 1980s
unlike the rest of the Communist World
there were no substantial reforms in the
economic and political system in North
Korea something that for example did
happen in its two mentors the Soviet
Union and China that left the North
Korean economy out of globalization and
without investment meaning that its
competitiveness gradually plummeted the
new Chinese factories were much more
productive thanks among other things to
ties with the west and so North Korean
companies and industries began to either
disappear or become so outdated that
they were no longer able to compete as a
result their exports plummeted let's
just say that while their Chinese and
South Korean neighbors were opening
their doors receiving foreign investment
and Technology North Korea was
completely left out of that process in
other words while China and South Korea
were catching up with the modern world
North Korea was like that guy who
refuses to stop wearing bell bottoms and
listening to cassette tapes on the other
hand the second and perhaps more
important reason is that starting in the
1970s and pushed even further in the
1980s North Korea began a huge program
of of military
expansion this program was aimed at
achieving full military Independence for
North Korea so that it would not be
dependent on either the Soviets or the
Chinese in the event of war the effects
of this decision were twofold on the one
hand an enormous amount of resources
were diverted from the civilian economy
to the military and on the other hand
the development of new infrastructure
that would strengthen the productive
economy was neglected for example the
road Network ports and water
infrastructure were completely neglected
which made North Korea very sensitive to
droughts and floods this was the
breeding ground for what came later the
arduous March although we will talk
about that a little later the fact is
that the militarization of the country
began to take a worrying turn in 1993
with the Communist block already
collapsed North Korea announced its
intention to withdraw from the nuclear
nonproliferation treaty and all this
despite the fact that it had ratified
the treaty 8 years earlier in 19 1994 it
cancelled its withdrawal but in 2003 It
ultimately ended up pulling out of the
agreement North Korea withdraws from
nuclear treaty pongyang said it was
reactivating the yangong beond
facilities to retaliate for Washington's
decision to suspend oil shipments after
the north revealed the existence of the
other clandestine nuclear program visual
politic Community the pongyang regime
began to pursue weapons of mass
destruction at any cost and this was a
fateful decision for its ailing economy
you see in the late 1990s the country
suffered a huge famine that killed
between half a million and 2 million
people depending on the source and even
in that situation the government never
stopped diverting money from military
development it even went so far as to
put obstacles in the way of
international Aid because it did not
allow foreign entities to manage Aid
programs let's just say that the regime
wanted to manage at all costs the
resources and money that were arriving
to mitigate the famine which many
interpreted as an attempt to divert part
of that Aid to other objectives that
were not precisely about saving lives
but the worst was Yet to
Come 3 years later in 2006 North Korea
conducted its first nuclear test which
was accompanied by the first package of
economic sanctions against the country
approved by the UN as well as unilateral
sanctions by several countries and while
it may come as a surprise to many of you
up until 2006 which is basically the day
before yesterday North Korea had an
economy perfectly capable of importing
and exporting whatever it wanted with
almost no limitations since its first
nuclear test however that has completely
changed North Korea has been punished by
more and more un Security Council
resolutions with
sanctions the Crux of the matter is not
so much the sanctions but the regime's
decision to self- imilate by launching a
large- scale nuclear development program
in the midst of a famine and completely
ignoring International reactions and you
know what from a political point of view
this strategy may have made sense for
the regime the proof 20 years later in
2023 the regime is still standing even
so from the point of view of its own
people and economy the idea could not
have been
worse following the Great Famine partly
as a result of the collapse of the
Communist block and North Korea's fall
in competitiveness the country never
recovered after the brutal fall
experienced in the 1990s its GDP per
capita is still at the same level as it
was in the 1960s we are talking about
six lost decades well there you have the
reasons why in North Korea the former
rising star of socialism ended up
becoming its greatest embarrassment the
question is will this situation last
forever at the moment there are no
changes in sight but as you know the
Korean Peninsula is a place we talk
about a lot on visual politic so we'll
keep an eye on it for now we invite you
to participate in this debate leaving
your thoughts Below in the comments and
of course if you liked this video don't
forget to like it and subscribe to our
channel so you don't miss any news once
again thank you for being there all the
best see you next
[Music]
time